herzlich willkommen zur folge
183 das faz einspruch podcast der
wöchentlichen podcast der faz für recht
justiz und politik heute am 27 oktober
mein name ist corinna budras und mit
dabei ist wieder
piano ransmayrs klein ja und wir haben
keine hausmitteilung sondern tauchen
direkt in die themen kurz und knackig
und das war total großartig kontakt
corinna du warst im bundestag gestern
damit fangen wir ein bisschen kleiner
stimmungsbericht daraus und dann wird es
sehr schnell ernst wir nähern uns dem
schwierigen thema es rückkehrer und da
schauen wir auf das urteil des olg
münchen das letzte woche gegen jennifer
w ergangen ist eine ziemlich
herzergreifende geschichte
und damit das nicht allzu groß wird und
wir nur so richtig schwere themen haben
haben wir danach das njw orange vor dem
bundesgerichtshof der hat letzte woche
ein urteil zur frage veröffentlicht ob
die njw weiterhin ihr orange nutzen kann
ja und njw muss man sagen es steht für
neue juristische wochenschrift für alle
nichtjuristen die das gar nicht kennen
aber das werden sie noch kennen lernt
das erkläre ich mache ja nochmal was die
njw ist und warum das einst so spannend
für die jura branche ist und dann habe
ich noch dabei bitcoins ein
ungewöhnliches thema für unseren rechts
podcast aber doch nicht so ungewöhnlich
wenn man sich überlegt dass das
justizministerium in nrw diese woche
bitcoins versteigert hat passiert jetzt
auch nicht alle tage berichte ich euch
mal kurz worum es da ging ja und dann
haben wir einen schwerpunkt zur
buchmesse auch das hat durchaus
juristische relevanz die ich mit meinem
vater und kollegen patrick bahners in
schon bewährter art und weise
reflektieren möchte geht nämlich um die
frage ob es echte verlage von der
buchmesse ausgeschlossen werden können
und dann haben wir noch zwei nachträge
und zwar einmal zur verurteilung des
drachen los des youtube was von dem wir
euch schon letzte woche berichtet hatten
und es gibt einen kleinen nachdreh wie
wir die journalistin und journalisten
sagen zum thema wie gucken ja immer so
nett sagt corona dinner also genauer
gesagt zur frage ob das
bundesverfassungsgericht
befangen gewesen sein oder befangen sein
könnte in sachen entscheidungen über
corona maßen haben konkret die bundes
notbremse ja und dann haben wir
natürlich noch gerichte urteil der woche
[Musik]
und dann steigen wir heute ein mit dem
bundestag corinna du warst gestern dort
in der konstituierenden sitzung des
größten bundestags aller zeiten ja für
deutschland ist das auf jeden fall so
wir haben ja dann noch ein parlament was
größer ist parlament muss man ja in
diesem zusammenhang sagen das ist der
chinesische volkskongress
die sind noch ein bisschen größer als
der bundestag aber wir haben ja jetzt
nun auch stattliche
abgeordnete vor das haben wir auch alle
über die wahlrechtsreform gesprochen
gestern das war ja durchaus mehrfach
thema habe ich gehört ja der soll
einfach kleiner werden das ist schon das
erklärte ziel gewesen
schon seit jahren das hat jetzt nun bei
der letzten wahl rechts reformen die
etwas merkwürdig ausgefallen ist nicht
so richtig geklappt
der ist jetzt sogar angewachsen von 709
volksvertretern zu
735 aber es besteht jedenfalls im
parlament im bundestag das dringende
bedürfnis das wieder zu reduzieren aber
es war wirklich eine sehr bunte truppe
muss man sagen aber es gibt natürlich
eine gewisse dominanz von juristen in
diesen ich dachte ehrlich gesagt du
sagst jetzt von männern aber juristen
ist auch sehr spanier männer es in der
tat natürlich auch korrekt als immer
noch nur ein drittel frauen
zwei drittel 65 prozent sind männer 35
prozent bilden frauen das ist eine
steigerung im vergleich zum letzten mal
aber jedenfalls sind wir noch lange
nicht
da wo jetzt eine einer paritätischen
besitz genommen
und wie gesagt es sind vor allen dingen
viele juristen die da offensichtlich
vorstellig geworden sind oder jedenfalls
den wahlkampf bestritten haben über 100
rechtsanwälte sind jetzt gehören dem
neuen bundestag an also über 100 von 735
das muss man sie plötzlich mal auf der
zunge zergehen lassen dass es schon
einen echten krass hoher anteil ja sind
etwa 14 prozent und wenn man das auf die
bevölkerung hochrechnen würde also wenn
man den anspruch hätte dass die
volksvertreter nicht nur die politische
diversität abbilden sondern auch noch in
etwa die berufe dann hätte gäbe es in
deutschland ein ernstes elf millionen
anwälte also muss das ganz ehrlich kann
niemand was ich machen konnte bis hin
zum vergleich es gibt jetzt ungefähr
sondern wie viel zugelassen 70.000 in
deutschland trauen dort weiß ich nicht
hab ich so was in den knochen etwas mehr
aber er
gut also dass dazu es gab natürlich so
den typischen
trotzdem jetzt so eine konstituierende
sitzung immer vorangeht ergebnis
ungewisse geschäftigkeit natürlich über
die geschäftsordnung abgestimmt und so
weiter und so fort und es tun sich wie
auch schon in dem der vergangenen
legislaturperiode creme auf zwischen der
afg und einen anderen parteien das muss
man schon deutlich so sagen dann aber
die sitzordnung war erstmal noch die
alten die seit wochen umstrittene
sitzordnung weil ja die fdp nicht mehr
nicht mehr neben der afg sitzen möchte
die sachsen aber jetzt gestern noch wie
in der letzten legislaturperiode oder
exakt genau da saßen noch relativ nah
dran es ist auch sehr gedrängt muss man
sagen bei 735
er wird schon der platz knapp da sitzt
man schon ziemlich backe backe
um sie jetzt mal so flapsig zu
formulierende das ist natürlich ein
unterschied ob da nur
vorgesehen sind ich glaube das ist
eigentlich die ursprüngliche zahl und
dann hatten wir schon auf diskutierten
liegt es natürlich an den
überhangmandaten und den
ausgleichsmandaten dass da so viele
abgeordnete sich drängen
vielen dank für diesen stimmungsbericht
aus dem bundestag jetzt kommen wir zu
einem wirklich harten thema nämlich die
e s rückkehrerin wie man immer irgendwie
so merkwürdig sagt jennifer weg die ist
anfang der woche vom olg münchen zu
einer gesamtfreiheitsstrafe von zehn
jahren haft verurteilt worden corinna
warum ja dagegen ist in zentralen
vorwurf um beihilfe zum versuchten mord
durch unterlassen weil sie dabei
zugeguckt haben soll wie ihr mann ein
kleines mädchen eine fünfjährige die bei
denen bei dem paar im haus wohnte als
sklaven gehalten wurde
sie hat dabei zugeguckt wie ihr mann
dieses kind bestraft hat und dieses kind
an einen in der prallen mittagssonne bei
über 40 grad
angehängt hat fest gebunden hat und hat
verdursten lassen und dabei ist sie
untätig geblieben hat den tod dieses
kindes in kauf genommen und dafür wurde
sie jetzt verurteilt
wer ist denn jennifer w wieso ist dieses
verfahren so relevant für uns wieso wird
das überhaupt in deutschland verhandelt
denn vw ist ja eine deutsche das muss
man jetzt dazu sagen um überhaupt mal zu
verstehen worum es hier geht und genau
und jennifer w ist insofern übrigens
auch besonders interessant weil 7 sie
hat ja gar keinen muslimischen
hintergrund eigentlich aber sie hatte
eine affinität
entwickelt zum zum islam nicht nur zum
islam sondern zum islamismus und zum zu
einer islamistischen terrororganisation
konkret geht es um den es ist eigentlich
aufgewachsen e-mini sachsen und kam dann
im jahr 2014 hat sie sich umorientiert
hat sich interessiert für den s und hat
beschlossen sich anzuschließen dieser
terror organisation dafür ist sie in den
nach syrien gereist und wurde dort
zunächst in frauenhäusern untergebracht
und ihrer mutter schrieb sie damals
tatsächlich sich fühle sich nun zu hause
und angekommen dass bespielte ihm im
verfahren eine rolle so und dann hat sie
sich auch tatsächlich mit männern
eingelassen die in dem für den es tätig
waren sie war zuerst mit einem mann
verheiratet dann ist diese ehe ich weiß
gar nicht ob sie in die brüche gegangen
ist oder jedenfalls war sie in zweiter
ehe dann mit einem anderen mann heiratet
ihn mit dem mann um den es hier konkret
geht und mit dem hat sie in falludscha
also in im irak gewohnt und hat ihm sehr
schnell nach der ihr nach nach der hat
nach der hochzeit deutlich gemacht dass
sie nicht in der lage ist und auch das
nicht wünscht sich um den haushalt zu
kümmern also scheint eine sehr resolute
person durchaus zu sein und hat dann
darauf gedrungen dass die unterstützung
im haushalt
bekommt und wie macht man das als es
terror ist man besorgt sich eines
knappen ja man besorgt sich eine sklavin
oder in diesem fall eben zwei also das
war einmal eine frau nora wird sie immer
genannt die eine fünfjährige tochter
hatte um diese tochter ging es dann
letztendlich und diese beiden
kaufte er auf einem markt in falludscha
und holte sie sich in den haushalt als
und hier zieht tatsächlich als sklaven
also so drastisch muss man sagen denn er
hat sie dort festgehalten und sie wurden
geschlagen sie wurden zur arbeit
gezwungen also das muss nun wirklich
schon auch im vorfeld dieser
abscheulichen taten muss es da wirklich
auch zu ereignissen kommen seien die
sehr sehr schrecklich waren und sehr
furchteinflößend für die mutter dann
ging es eben vor gericht tatsächlich um
einen konkreten tag an dem es wirklich
sehr heiß gewesen sein muss da draußen
und es ging darum dass dieses kleine
mädchen
sich ein gemacht hatte also tatsächlich
die
wohl krank und hatte nachts ins bett
gemacht genau richtig und der der mann
hat das mädchen gezwungen das sauber zu
machen und wollte sie ihn bestrafen
gleichzeitig dafür und kam dann auf die
wirklich abscheulich idee dieses mädchen
in die pralle sonne zu stellen sie da
fest zu ketten am fenster so dass sie
auch nicht weg konnte sie hing
tatsächlich so dass sie mit dem gesicht
in die sonne
schaute und sich auch nicht befreien
konnte und sie lief immer nach ihrer
mutter ihre mutter hat das wohl im haus
auch gehört aber sie konnte nichts tun
weil sie natürlich selbst fürchterliche
angst vor diesem mann hat der schon
zuvor geschlagen hatte und misshandelt
hatte genau die mutter musste weiter das
haus putzen während ihr kind in der
sonne verdurstet ist ja und dann war es
tatsächlich so dass irgendwann einfach
nichts mehr zu hören war und
offensichtlich dann erst der mann
das mädchen ab dann feststellte dass sie
ohnmächtig war und dann hat er dieses
mädchen ins krankenhaus gebracht aber
dort ist sie dann tatsächlich vor
gestorben so und in diesem prozess ging
es um die rolle die wirklich sehr
merkwürdige rolle von der frau die die
ganze zeit dabei war und nicht
eingeschritten ist
die also dazu geguckt hat ihren mann
darauf einmal darauf hingewiesen hat
dass man auf dieses kind wird sterben
daran konnte man deutlich sehen dass sie
tatsächlich auch die dramatik der
situation erkannt hatte aber mehr hat
sie einfach auch nicht getan und vor
gericht wurde natürlich auch
erheblich
nachgeforscht und gefragt warum haben
sie sind sie dann nicht eingeschritten
und die antwort war tatsächlich weil ich
angst hatte geschubst oder eingesperrt
zu werden also das war die sachlage die
das gericht zu verhandeln hatte und die
kamen dann das gericht kam dann am
montag tatsächlich zum schluss dass das
ganze
eine beihilfe zum versuchten mord durch
unterlassen gewesen ist
weil die jennifer w das hat der richter
so gesagt von anfang an damit rechnen
musste dass das in der sonnenhitze
gefesselte kind sich in lebensgefahr
befand und sie habe nichts unternommen
um die mädchen zu helfen obwohl ihr das
8 im juristendeutsch möglich und
zumutbar gewesen sei also ich glaube das
ist noch eine relativ charmante
formulierung möglich und zumutbar denn
wenn man da ernsthaft einwendet ich
hatte angst geschubst oder eingesperrt
zu werden dann ist das natürlich
freundlich ausgedrückt ein schwaches
argument der absolut also dass das war
wirklich auch sehr ist einfach nur
bestürzender so was zu hören vielleicht
muss man hier auch nochmal bei der
gelegenheit erklären warum es nur ein
versuchter mord es denn das gericht geht
davon aus dass das kind daran gestorben
ist mache ich wenn ich das übrigens so
formulieren dann muss man vielleicht
noch mal kurz erklären dass der dieses
kind verschwunden ist ja also sehr der
man es mit dem kind ins krankenhaus
gefahren kam zurück und hat behauptet
das ist noch am leben er behauptet dass
auch immer noch er wird übrigens auch
selber vor gericht gestellt das ist ein
verfahren weil es jetzt gerade in
frankfurt stattfindet und er
behauptet eben das kind sei dann vom
krankenhaus wo auch immer hin gekommen
aber jedenfalls ist es nicht mehr daran
ist auch nicht mehr bei seiner mutter
nora und deswegen das war eine der
vielen knackpunkte und schwierigkeiten
auch bei diesem verfahren die die
beweiswürdigung in diesem zusammenhang
ist immer sehr sehr schwierig aber hier
war eben auch das
problem dass eben der
also unklar war sozusagen
zunächst ist dieses kind überhaupt
gestorben da hat das gericht ganz klar
gesagt wir sind zum ergebnis gekommen
dass das so war dass es tot ist aber es
ist eben unklar und deswegen nur
beihilfe am versuchten mord ob
tatsächlich die frau etwas daran hätte
ändern können ja also ob sozusagen ihre
eingriffsmöglichkeiten so waren dass sie
den tod tatsächlich verhindern könnte
deswegen diese merkwürdige konstruktion
des der beihilfe zum versuchten mord
durch unterlassen also es geht ja jetzt
auch nicht nur in anführungszeichen um
den versuchten mord durch unterlassen
sondern sie ist auch noch verurteilt
wurden wegen mitgliedschaft in der
terroristischen vereinigung im ausland
natürlich eben mes und wegen verbrechen
gegen die menschlichkeit mit todesfolgen
genau ich also das sind schon und auch
einige straftatbestände die dazukommen
und sicherlich dieses diese
gesamtfreiheitsstrafe von zehn jahren
auch als auch gut erklären allerdings
muss man sagen die bundesanwaltschaft
hatte eine lebenslange freiheitsstrafe
gefordert
die hatten auch angeklagt wegen
vollendeten mordes dann wäre man
natürlich ohnehin bei einer lebenslangen
freiheitsstrafe
gelandet die verteidigung hatte
allerdings gesagt wir hätten gerne eine
maximal zweijährige haftstrafe nur wegen
mitgliedschaft in der terroristischen
vereinigung es ist nicht rechtskräftig
oder kochen
dass das urteil ist nicht rechtskräftig
ich habe gestern kontakt aufgenommen mit
der verteidigerin von jennifer w und die
sagte dass sie damit rechnen dass die
bundesanwaltschaft in revision gehen
wird denn wie gesagt
richtig die haben ja lebenslang
gefordert und sind wohl auch ziemlich
enttäuscht von dem urteil die
verteidigerin selber sagte sie können
mit diesem urteil leben denn sie haben
ja in der tat wenig zwar wesentlich
weniger gefordert aber
werten das durchaus als erfolg für ihre
mandantin dieses urteil insoweit mann
ist in diesen schrecklichen fall so
sagen kann weil er hier immer von einem
minderschweren fall ausgegangen wird
dass hatten die eben
versucht durchzusetzen und waren damit
auch erfolgreich und würden jetzt aber
mal dass ihr weiteres vorgehen davon
abhängig machen ob die
bundesanwaltschaft in revision geht und
ob dieses urteil nochmals aufgerollt
wird
interessant okay ich wollte aber doch
noch mal vielleicht klären dieser fall
ist natürlich irgendwie ich meine an ein
kind in der sonne verdursten zu lassen
sterben zu lassen ist natürlich maximal
grausam sozusagen aber das ist natürlich
nicht der grund dafür warum er bei
diesem fall so viel gesprochen wird und
warum auch über diese verurteilung so
viel gesprochen wird und die zum teil
richtig gefeiert wird das ist ja im
prinzip im einzelfall der aber schon
steht für was viel größeres warum ist
das jetzt so ein relevanter sollte ja
wir haben jetzt schon seit einiger zeit
die es mit i s rückkehr anzutun so will
man wird das ja immer formulierte also
wir haben jetzt ja seit neuesten das
phänomen dass wir viele
auch interessanterweise deutsche
staatsbürger haben die sich dem i s
angeschlossen haben auch anderen
terroristischen vereinigungen aber es
geht immer im wesentlichen um den es die
nach syrien ausgereist sind die in den
irak gereist sind die damit gemacht
haben und deswegen eben dann auch schon
per se den
straftatbestand der beteiligung an einer
ausländischen terroristischen
vereinigung nach paragraph 129b
strafgesetzbuch um das hier mal zu
nennen verwirklicht haben und dass die
jetzt mitunter zurückkommen amazon oder
maßen oder freiwillig oder weil sie
geläutert sind also auf jeden fall haben
wir es jetzt hier schon seit einiger
zeit damit zu tun dass wir die es
rückkehrer hier in deutschland empfangen
die irgendwie vor gericht stellen müssen
ja also insofern ist das hier ein
einfall der in diese linie passt aber
der natürlich durch diesen besonderen
fall des verletzten kindes hier
besonders schwierig ist und besonders in
den blickpunkt der öffentlichkeit
gerückt ist naja dieses kind und diese
und auch seine mutter die übrigens wohl
in sehr
emotionalen und schwierigen auftritten
auch in münchen aufgetreten ist als
nebenklägerin und die übrigens vertreten
wird von amal clooney der frau von
george clooney ihres zeichens eine sehr
bekannte menschenrechtlerin die
allerdings in münchen nie aufgetaucht
ist jedenfalls diese mutter ist
natürlich wie auch das vom mutmaßlich
verstorbene kind jesiden und diese
beiden stehen quasi auch dafür dass dass
es sozusagen damit erstmals jemand
angeklagt wurde wegen der straftaten die
der es gerade gegen die religiöse
minderheit der jesiden begangen hat also
da gab es quasi einen völkermord vor
allem im jahr 2014 hat er es mehr als
5000 jesiden und jesiden getötet und
töten lassen und die werden eben dessen
religiöse minderheit die massiv verfolgt
werden vom es und eben nicht nur
verfolgt sondern wenn man ihrer habhaft
wird gerade wenn es frauen sind dann
eben gerne auch mal fast kraft werden
vergewaltigt werden usw von daher wird
das eben auch von dieser religiösen
minderheit der jesiden
sehr sehr ja ich sag mal wirklich
gefeiert dass dieses urteil gefallen ist
weil das schon als eine art von von
gerechtigkeit und sühne empfunden wird
dass damit jetzt erstmals jemand vor
einem ordentlichen gericht in
deutschland steht und für diese
straftaten gegen die religiöse
minderheit der jesiden verurteilt wurde
ja richtig also es wirklich eine
wahnsinnig schwierige gemengelagen auch
die kicker in der ganze prozess war habe
ich sehr sehr schwierig hat hatte viele
hürden zu überspringen also allein das
sieht man ja schon an den 77 vorhanden
tagen die für dieses diesen fall
nötig waren es gab viele beweis
schwierigkeiten die mutter des kindes
nora ist eben aufgetreten und da hat man
sehr schnell festgestellt wie schwierig
es auch ist mit mit diesen sehr
kulturellen unterschieden und sozialen
unterschieden dann auch fertig zu werden
also die die mutter so beschreibt das
eine reportage in der süddeutschen
zeitung sehr schön
die mutter hatte einen sprachfehler oder
hat einen sprachfehler und das ist
deswegen selbst für leute die die
sprache beherrschen nur sehr schwer zu
verstehen und dann ist sie analphabetin
und hat eben schwierigkeit auch den
kontext von solchen situationen genau
darzulegen also wie lange dem fall ja
auch vor allem die die zeitlichen
zusammen genau die sollte ja darüber
aussagen wie lange ihre tochter da
draußen angekettet war angesagt und am
ende stellte sich irgendwie heraus dass
sie eigentlich gar nicht genau wusste
was ist denn eine halbe stunde oder was
ist eine stunde weil sie die uhr gar
nicht lesen kann ja genau also also was
sind in schwierigkeiten mit der man mit
denen man dann umgehen muss in so einem
verfahren also deswegen hat sehr lange
gedauert wie gesagt es gab die
unterschiedlichen aussagen auch das des
mannes der wie gesagt selber angeklagt
ist und sich da auch noch ein verfahren
stellen muss also das ist alles nicht
ganz einfach man hat es jetzt quasi über
die bühne gebracht wird eben sehen wie
das jetzt vor dem bundesgerichtshof
bestand hat dieses urteil und wie ihr in
die bundesanwaltschaft ich werde also
wenn die rechts mit leistung das kann ja
auch theoretisch immer noch sein dass
sie sagen kommen irgendwie zehn jahre
erreichen uns auch aber in der tat was
ist natürlich irgendwie alleine schon
wegen der wegen der qualifikation als
versuchter mord und so kann man schon
darüber nachdenken ob man da nicht noch
mal rein geht ja
gut also es gibt gelbe in der tat noch
viel mehr dazu zu erzählen aber ich
würde sagen hier machen wir jetzt mal
einen punkt weil es ja doch auch
wirklich ein sehr schweres thema ist und
kommen jetzt zu etwas leichter
das sagst du so ich bin mir gar nicht
mal so sicher ob das der beck verlag
auch so sieht nein spaß das ist
natürlich überhaupt nicht vergleichbar
ich habe euch eine bgh-entscheidung
mitgebracht denn der bundesgerichtshof
hat in der vergangenen woche seine
entscheidung veröffentlicht über das
orange also die farbe orange tender in
juristischen wochenschrift und im intro
habe ich ja schon verbockt das heißt die
njw kennen alle juristinnen und juristen
aber vielleicht für die nichtjuristen
die uns zuhören die neue juristische
wochenschrift ist deutschlands
auflagenstärkste und vermutlich auch
traditionsreichste fachzeitschrift für
juristinnen und juristen
dieses verfahren ist also unter zwei
gesichtspunkten eigentlich spannend
nämlich einmal rechtlich weil der bgh
seine rechtsprechung verändert hat zur
darlegungs und beweislast in forschungs
verfahren im markenrecht ok muss jetzt
nicht jeder spannend finden aber es ist
auf jeden fall auch faktisch interessant
weil es eben in um die njw geht die njw
vielleicht erklärt erst mal so zu sagen
in welchem in welchem zusammenhang
befinden wir uns eigentlich also warum
spielte das überhaupt vor gericht eine
rolle dass die enbw sich in orange
gekleidet
genau also die njw kleidet sich genauer
gesagt schon seit 1976 in orange die
haben also immer dasselbe orange für das
cover benutzt das kann man sieht auch
immer relativ ähnlich aus das wurde
natürlich mal ein bisschen modernisiert
von den schriftarten und so ansonsten
ist es aber seitdem immer in diesem
match gehalten und im jahr 2008 hat an
der beck verlag beantragt dass das als
farb- marke eingetragen wird das ist im
jahr 2009 auch geschehen und das ist gar
nicht mal so selbstverständlich denn
einfach nur eine farbe als marke
eintragen zu lassen das bedarf schon wie
einige anforderungen weil normalerweise
ist ja eine marke irgendwie was was also
zum beispiel irgendwie eine bestimmte
schriftart enthält und so und nur eine
farbe hat eigentlich per se kaum
unterscheidungskraft man das im
markenrecht nennt und da muss man
vielleicht noch mal einen haken kurz und
sagen dass das natürlich dann auch immer
für die wettbewerbern problem es sei
also in dem moment wurden eine marke
eingetragen wird kann jetzt zum beispiel
auch keinen wettbewerb arbeiten mit
allen juristischen
fachzeitschrift rauskommen und die
inklusion nutzen halten
ja also ohne deswegen hat der beck
verlag das natürlich auch gemacht und
zwar mit der begründung naja das ist
jetzt vielleicht nur eine farbe und so
weiter aber er würde die farbe seit
jahrzehnten für den hev totschlag der
njw nutzen und deshalb sei das quasi
verkehrs durchgesetzt also er hat von
anfang an gesagt ich möchte das anmelden
als verkehrs durch gesetzte marke für
juristische fachzeitschrift
das hat auch damals funktioniert und das
wurde eingetragen im jahr 2009 also
diese durch benutzung im verkehr
durchgesetzt muss man vielleicht schon
ein bisschen erklären das liegt dann vor
wenn quasi ein zeichen also was als
marke angemeldet werden soll hier eben
diese farbe so bekannt wird dass es von
den angesprochenen verkehrskreise nein
produkt und einem hersteller zugeordnet
wird also ein klassisches beispiel ist
zum beispiel nivea das nivea blau das
kennt halt irgendwie jeder mensch und
jeder mensch würde das sofort irgendwie
in verbindung auch mit dem schriftzug
auch wenn da gar nicht irgendwie nivea
stünde würde das diesem diesem produkt
und dem hersteller zu ordnen das ist
einfach wirklich so ein klassischer fall
wo man sagt das ist ein klassischer
farbwerke wo man es wirklich mal kennt
und da der beck verlag gesagt das hätten
wir auch gerne das muss man im
markenrecht an immer zu ordnen also
waren oder produkten oder
dienstleistungen und daneben hierfür
juristischen fachzeitschriften so weit
so gut wurde alles eingetragen alles
fein bis zum jahr 2015 dann ging die
geschichte nämlich etwas unschöne weiter
denn eine
rechtsanwältin und verlegerin hat einen
durchschuss antrag gestellt und hat
gesagt das stimmt gar nicht dieses
orange ist überhaupt nicht verkehrs
durchgesetzt so
so und wie ging es dann weiter
ja dann will wurde natürlich über diesen
löschung sant rat entschieden und zwar
erstmal vom bundespatentgericht
2020 ist das passiert ich sage kurz
warum das relevant ist später und das
bundespatentgericht hat sich dann die
ganze kiste angeschaut und kam zu dem
ergebnis ich zitiere es dürfte kaum
einen juristen in deutschland geben der
die njw mit ihrer typischen
orangefarbenen titelseite
ich kenne es handele sich um eines der
wichtigsten und verbreiteten
arbeitsmittel für jung und da geht es
auch tatsächlich nur um juristen also
sozusagen ob jetzt ein mathematiker des
alls in jw erkennt es total schnuppe man
guckt sozusagen die betroffenen oder den
kreis von kunden an die das ansprechen
wird genau also es geht tatsächlich um
die sozusagen die verkehrskreise die
sich damit beschäftigen also man guckt
sich dann immer so ein bisschen an wie
sieht das denn aus mit umsatz mit dem
marktanteil mit der intensität der
nutzung der marke wie verbreitet ist die
von wem wird die sozusagen gesehen also
es geht schon darum wer ist die die dass
das adressierte marktsegment und das ist
natürlich mit den mit den juristen die
es in deutschland gibt relativ klein es
wurde jahrzehntelang genutzt und das
bundespatentgericht hat eben auch darauf
abgestellt dass die njw hat so eine
wahnsinnig bekannte zeitschrift das mit
einer wirklich irre hohen auflage das
wird dann immer geprüft zum zeitpunkt
der anmeldung der marke und zu dem
zeitpunkt als der löschung sun über den
leistungsantrag entschieden wurde also
quasi als das bundespatentgericht dann
entschieden hat und im jahr 2009 hatte
die njw noch eine auflage von 43.000 und
es ist eine wöchentlich erscheinende
zeitschrift das ist also enorm viel und
auch im jahr 2018 als der löschung
antrag gestellt wurde lag die auflage
wohl noch so irgendwie zwischen sieben
und 20.000 30.000 dass es natürlich mit
blick auf die allgemeine
marktentwicklung weil es ja eben jetzt
viel mehr digitale angebote gibt immer
noch ein wahnsinnig großer marktanteil
und dann hat das bundespatentgericht
habe ich auch sehr spannend und auch
gesagt juristische zeitschriften würden
ja zu dem auch nicht nur von jedem leser
selbst erworben und gelesen sondern die
legen ja auch noch überall roben also in
der uni genau und diesmal so drin rum
und so und wir haben die gesagt es gibt
eben auch noch viel viel mehr leserinnen
und leser als diese auflage sozusagen
vermuten lässt so und die haben eben
auch darauf abgestellt dass in der
presse die njw vielfach als
pflichtlektüre bezeichnet wird und als
bedeutendstes zeitschrift für die
juristische theorie und praxis das ist
natürlich auch deswegen so ein bisschen
lustig weil das bundespatentgericht
dabei zum teil aufgrund eigener
sachkunde
der tag einwerben berüchtigte
gerichtsbekannt nun ist jetzt passiert
wahrscheinlich auch nicht alle tage dass
man bei so einer kleinen zielgruppe als
richter am bundespatentgericht mal sagen
mensch ich bin selbst teil der
angesprochenen verkehrskreise und kann
da irgendwie aus eigener anschauung
entscheiden das ist in diesem fall aber
geschehen es gab also kein gutachten
oder sowas
sondern am ende hat das
bundespatentgericht gesagt also wir
glauben dass die mj wie ich es richtig
dolle bekannt ist und zwar inklusive
ihres orange und das dass damit auch
identifiziert wird aber es blieben wohl
schon noch zweifel ob das dann wirklich
am ende für eine verkehrs durchsetzung
reicht zu diesem zeitpunkt und deswegen
sagte ich vorhin schon das war dann
anfang 2020 als das bundespatentgericht
entschieden hat galt noch nach ständiger
bgh rechtsprechung dass solche zweifel
zu lasten der antragstellerin im
lösungsverfahren ging also zu lasten der
hiesigen antragstellerin im
lösungsverfahren die konnte wohl mich so
richtig überzeugen so und dann kam aber
blöderweise im oktober 2020 also wenige
monate später der europäische
gerichtshof um die ecke und zwar in der
sache ferrari testarossa beim
europäischen gerichtshof haben ja die
sachen immer nahmen vor allem im bereich
markenrecht und gewerblicher
rechtsschutz und hat seine
rechtsprechung geändert nämlich die
beweislast und zwar auch im lösch und
dem anmeldeverfahren im markenrecht und
dem musste der bgh natürlich folgen das
heißt als die ganze kiste dann jetzt
beim bgh gelandet ist im jahr 20 21 da
musste der bgh sich an die bh
rechtsprechung anpassen und kam zum
selben ergebnis wie das
bundespatentgericht hat gesagt na ja es
gibt schon irgendwie anhaltspunkte dafür
dass die die das orange der njw verkehrs
durchgesetzt ist aber es bleiben eben
noch zweifel übrig und diese
zweifelsregelung hat sich jetzt geändert
das heißt jetzt geht die
zweifelsregelung zu lasten des bag
verlags aus und nicht mehr wie beim
bundespatentgericht zugunsten des bag
fall so der muss jetzt zeigen dass die
juristen mit dem orange in überwiegender
mehrheit
die mjd verbinde und die macht man das
das macht man in aller regel mit einem
gutachten ein sogenanntes
verkehrsgutachten da gibt es mehrere
institute bundesweit die kann man google
die sich damit beschäftigen solche
gutachten zu erstellen das wird aller
voraussicht nach der beck verlag jetzt
auch tun also ich habe auch natürlich
nochmal beim beck-verlag angerufen aber
der pressesprecher hat gesagt sie
möchten sich eigentlich zu dem laufenden
verfahren nicht äußern
sie gehen aber weiterhin davon aus dass
die verkehrs durchsetzung gegeben ist
ich zitiere jede juristin und jeder
jurist kennt die orangene njw das heißt
jetzt wird der beck verlag halt im
zweifel ein gutachten einholen
vielleicht warten die auch ab was das
bundespatentgericht sagt aber gerade bei
farb- marken wie gesagt meine farbe
ebenso per se gar keine eigene
unterscheidungskraft hat ist es in der
regel so dass man gutachten braucht um
eine verkehrs durchsetzung wirklich
nachzuweisen und am ende müsste diese
verkehrs durchsetzung bei mehr als 50
prozent liegen das gutachten müsste also
zu dem ergebnis kommen dass mehr als 50
prozent der deutschen juristinnen und
juristen das orange der njw und dem
beck-verlag zuordnen naja also dieses
verfahren wird uns vielleicht noch ein
bisschen beschäftigen
ja aber dann kommen wir jetzt zu einem
kuriosen thema das ich jetzt vielleicht
auch viele jetzt juristen auch irritiert
oder überrascht hat jedenfalls also ich
hab bin gestolpert über eine
pressemitteilung des
justizministeriums in nordrhein
westfalen die gesagt haben anfang der
woche wir versteigern jetzt mal ein paar
bitcoins wie kam es denn dazu
das waren sogar mehr als ein paar das
waren insgesamt 215 bitcoins bedeutet im
wert von mehreren millionen euro wieso
macht dass das nordrhein westfälische
justizministerium
also in nrw und das muss man sagen ist
das justizministerium das bundesweit
einzige und zentrale online
auktionsportal der deutschen justiz für
deutschland und österreich
das heißt das justizministerium in nrw
macht ständig so eine art laufende
auktion
wo verfallene oder eingezogene
gegenstände versteigert werden also
gegenstände die aus straftaten
eingezogen wurden beschlagnahmt wurden
und so weiter und die dann eben
irgendwann nicht an die täter zurück
gegeben werden müssen sondern die werden
versteigert und so in diesem fall auch
bitcoins denn bekanntlich sind ja
bitcoins nicht nur eine mittlerweile
recht salon fähige digital währung
sondern auch sehr viele kriminelle
nutzen bitcoins um kriminelle handlungen
abzudecken und zu bezahlen das heißt
diese bitcoins wurde nebenbei
kriminellen entdeckt und sichergestellt
und dann jetzt versteigert werden dazu
möchte ich einmal kurz dafür werbung
machen dem justizministerium nrw auf
jeden fall bei twitter zu folgen denn
die
ist ein wirklich richtig lustige account
ich weiß nicht genau welches großartige
social media team dahinter steht oder ob
es überhaupt als gibt im
justizministerium nrw wer auch immer
diesen account macht erst richtig lustig
die zeigen relativ häufig lustige dinge
die dann versteigert werden also ich
habe gestern noch mal reingeschaut
aktuell gibt es zum beispiel einen lotus
zu kaufen also ein auto man könnte aber
auch ein paar fahren ersteigern oder
eine schwalbe so ein altes motorrad so
einem moped irgendwie es gibt auch einen
buggy und ein ich zitiere konvolut von
kosmetika 70 teile für nur schnupper
mäßige 25 euro bei der sterne der
einstiegspreis das heißt genau das ist
immer der einstiegspreis dann muss man
das eben ersteigern vielleicht muss man
noch mal kurz dazu was sagen warum das
ganze eigentlich versteigert wird das
ergibt sich aus der strafvollstreckung
ordnung die schreibt in paragraf 63
absatz 2 vor dass verfallen oder
eingezogene gegenstände regelmäßig im
wege der versteigerung verwertet sind
soweit vom gesetz nichts anderes
bestimmt ist und so richtig gibt es halt
keine andere bestimmung für virtuelle
währungen also da gibt es tatsächlich
auch eine vorschrift 77a in der
strafvollstreckung ordnung und die sieht
die verwertung über eine zentrale
einrichtung vor sagt aber nichts dazu
wie jetzt eigentlich dieser verkauf dann
vonstatten gehen muss unter scheint es
so gewesen zu sein dass das wirklich das
ministerium auch mehrere gutachten in
auftrag gegeben hat die dann rauskriegen
sollten so erstens können wir nicht die
bitcoins einfach mal in euro umtauschen
ergebnis der gutachten geht nicht
sondern diese bitcoins müssen als
bitcoins quasi verwertet werden und dann
haben sie eben gesagt naja da dann diese
vorschrift im 77a keine keine nichts
darüber aussagt wie man das jetzt
vernünftig verwertet dann nehmen wir den
gesetzlichen regelfall und machen das
als versteigerung ja also das ist doch
eine schöne geschichte kann man mal
weiter im auge behalten herzlichen dar
denn es gibt noch viel mehr davon es
gibt noch viel viel mehr bitcoins also
dass justiz also das justizministerium
in nrw hat wohl ungefähr noch zwölf
einhalb millionen euro die sie schon
beschlagnahmt und gesichert haben und
die dann jetzt wahrscheinlich sukzessive
in die versteigerung gegeben werden
allerdings muss man sagen dass
vielleicht noch zum abschluss es wurde
zum teil mehr geboten als der bitcoin
gleichzeitig an der börse wert war es
fast schon ein wenig irritiert das ist
da sind auch die staatsanwälte dann wohl
nachgefragt worden in nrw und die hatten
auch nicht so richtig eine antwort
darauf sie haben nur gemutmaßt dass die
leute die da eben bitcoins ersteigern ja
dann auch sicher wissen dass sie die
bitcoins auch kriegen und das kann
natürlich tatsächlich ein argument sein
denn manchmal weiß man ja nicht ganz so
genau wo eigentlich bitcoins herkommen
und ob man sie dann am ende auch kriegt
nachdem man sie bezahlt haben von daher
wäre also ein bisschen sicherheit haben
möchte aber in dieses werde bitcoin
geschäft einsteigen der kann vor allem
den twitter account des
justizministeriums nrw im auge behalten
sehr schön jetzt kommen wir aber zum
schwerpunktthema unser woche nämlich zu
den turbulenzen die es auf der
frankfurter buchmesse gegeben hat denn
dazu habe ich mich mit meinem förderung
kollegen patrick bahners vorab geredet
viel spaß
[Musik]
cabanas sie sind gerade zurück von der
frankfurter buchmesse die in diesem jahr
von der forderung dominiert wurde doch
endlich rechte verlage rauszuschmeißen
vielleicht klären sie uns erstmal auf
worum geht es eigentlich
diese diskussion wurde ausgelöst durch
eine schriftstellerin die im rowohlt
verlag jetzt gerade ihren roman
veröffentlicht hat jasmina kunkel das
ist eine afro deutsche autorin die auch
unter anderem auf twitter und in den
sozialen medien in der modernen
öffentlichkeit nicht nur sehr präsent
sondern auch sehr aktiv ist sich sehr
stark exponiert und deswegen unter
anderem auch schon persönlichen
drohungen ausgesetzt war aus
rechtsradikalen kreisen und sie
fürchtete um ihre persönliche sicherheit
wenn sie in frankfurt auftritt und
kritisierte dass eine bühne wo sie
eigentlich auftreten sollte in
unmittelbarer nähe eines verlags stand
zwar eines verlages der heißt jung
europa verlag der ein ich würde sagen
rechts intellektuelles programm vertritt
und schon seid 2017 wird eigentlich
jedes jahr darüber diskutiert ob diese
sogenannten rechten verlage rechts
intellektuellen politisch vielleicht
rechtsextremen verlage ob die überhaupt
auf der buchmesse vertreten sein sollten
frau kuhn gehabt dann eben gesagt
persönlich wollte sie dann nicht nach
frankfurt kommen und diesen von ihr
persönlich erklärten boykott haben sich
dann einige andere einzelne autoren
angeschlossen und in der in der
literatur szene wurde dann eben viel
darüber debattiert ist es jetzt zu dass
dadurch dass die buchmesse gesagt hat
sie sieht sich außerstande
diesen kritisierten verlag
auszuschließen und dadurch sind eben
einige autoren und autorinnen nicht
gekommen ob das so zu sagen jetzt ein
sieg der sogenannten rechten war die
damit eben die von den von den rechten
bedrohten personen aus frankfurt fallen
jetzt gucken wir uns vielleicht zunächst
einmal diesen verlag an sie haben gesagt
der heißt jung europa mir ist er nicht
bekannt oder war eigentlich bekannt für
diese diskussion was hat er so im
angebot wer steckt dahinter dieser name
jung europa
weist schon auf die ideen für die der
verlag steht das ist letztlich eine
ideenwelt die in die zwanziger jahre
zurückgeht in die zeit der konservativen
revolution
wo ein radikaler konservatismus
vertreten wird das ist ja an sich schon
paradox natürlich also politische ideen
die gewöhnlich eben dem rechten spektrum
am rechten rand eingeordnet werden und
wo der nationalismus
mehr oder weniger die hauptidee ist
unter der die leute sich sammeln wo dann
aber auch in abgrenzung eben vom
nationalsozialismus
sehr betont wird dass eben natürlich in
der sich dieser autoren und der leute
die dann so ein verlag aufmachen auch
jede nation ihr recht eben auf ihren
eigenen nationalismus habe das erklärt
warum nun ein
verlag mit einem nationalistischen
programm sich jung europa verlag nennt
und ein bekannter autor der dort verlegt
wird ist einer der einer der haupt
denker der neuen rechten also der
rechten oder rechtsextremen
intellektuellen die so in den in den
1970 er jahren
prominent geworden ist das ist der
franzose alain delon und der hat
sozusagen diese ideen aus den 20er
jahren noch mal erneuert steht für einen
sogenannten ethno pluralismus also für
die vorstellung dass eben die völker
sich sozusagen sortieren sollten und auf
verschiedene staaten verteilen sollten
und unter sich bleiben sollten wenn ich
das so referieren kommt glaube ich schon
heraus wieso ein verlag der solche ideen
vertritt natürlich in einer
demokratischen pluralistischen
gesellschaft eine randposition
einnimmt aber ob diese ideen wirklich so
randständig sind und vor allem dann auch
praktisch so gefährlich sind dass daraus
eine gefährdung für leute die eben gegen
diese ideen kämpfen unmittelbar entsteht
das ist die frage die dann letzte woche
in frankfurt für so viel streit gesungen
hat vielleicht nochmal
präzise nachgefragt also es geht
natürlich schon um russisches
gedankengut also um eine rassistische
stoßrichtung das ist mir jetzt etwas das
ist mir jetzt etwas zu eins auf das
befinden vermisse ich eben auch bei den
leuten die in der letzten woche diese
kampagne angezettelt haben wo wogegen
diesen verlag aber auch gegen einige
andere verlage also etwa ein bekannter
ist dann schon der anti oz verlag von
götz kubitschek um sogenannte institut
für staatspolitik für meinen geschmack
sind sind da die kritiker viel zu
einfach bei der hand mit solchen
etiketten wie faschismus oder nazi und
auch machen es sich vielleicht etwas zu
leicht mit diesem begriff des rassismus
die fragen nicht jetzt dann nach wenn
ich darauf ausführlich antwort müsste
müsste ich im grunde eine eine kritik
dieses verlagsprogramms
machen und ihr nicht kennen sich eben an
dieser kampagne aus der letzten woche
dass diejenigen die für einen ausschluss
dieser verlage sind sich diese mühe
überhaupt nicht mehr machen dass da
eigentlich der verdacht regiert und der
wille regiert diese die ideen eben noch
nicht mal mehr überhaupt zur kenntnis
zu nehmen worauf ich hinaus volt ist
sozusagen ob es da klare strafrechtliche
vorwürfe gibt gegen den autor oder teile
des meines wissens nicht also es ist so
dass gibt persönliche verbindungen auch
aus diesem jungen europa verlag china
diesem jahr ziemlich alle jäger angeht
ein gewisser philipp stein dieser
philipp stein hat einen verein gegründet
der heißt ein prozent das ist ein verein
der sich mit radikale rhetorik einsetzt
gegen die herrschende
migrationspolitik insofern auch eine
ganz klar nationalistische agenda
vertritt und dieser name ist er
vielleicht etwas merkwürdig 1 prozent
damit drücken die leute ihre überzeugung
aus es würden 1 prozent in einem volk
genügen die überzeugt sind von einer
bestimmten sache um die anderen 99
prozent die lauen sozusagen zu
überzeugen es gibt es in amerika ähnlich
da gab es bei den leuten die das capitol
gestürmt haben am sechsten januar
gruppen auch radikale dort auch wirklich
bewaffnete gruppen die nennen sich
sweeper centers also die amerikaner
warum auch immer die amerikanischen
rechten haben dann etwas andere rechnung
die sagen also wir müssen drei prozent
überzeugen und dann können wir die sache
zum kippen bringen hier ist es ist es
ein prozent und dieser verein wird
tatsächlich als so genannter
verdachtsfall vom verfassungsschutz
beobachten also das ist im grunde
genommen der ansatzpunkte also auch das
hauptargument weshalb man jetzt die
kritiker auch sagen den wollen wir hier
nicht auf unserer buchmesse haben weil
es immerhin quasi diese staatliche in
anführungsstrichen
maßnahmen gibt er aber sind ja nur
maßnahmen an der beobachtung und ich
finde eben auch sehr kurz schlüssig dass
das eben leute aus dem die
literaturbranche aus dem verlagswesen
sagen wenn hier im verfassungsschutz
jemand erwähnt wird es wird ja noch
nicht mal der verlag erwähnt es wird ja
nur der verein erwähnt aber selbst wenn
der verlag erwähnt würde tatsächlich
steht dort dass der verein eben auch mit
publizistischen mitte für seine sache
werbung macht ich finde es schon sehr
befremdlich dass man eben dass man eben
sagt wenn der verfassungsschutz den
verdacht hat dass sei
verfassungsfeindlich und vielleicht
sogar gefährlich für den staat das dann
in der buchbranche leute hingehen und
sagen wir wollen mit denen nichts mehr
zu tun haben andere falle verleger zu
verstehen geben wir wollen eigentlich
nicht in einen riesigen raum wo ja man
sich aus dem weg gehen kann gemeinsam
ausstellen mit einem mit einem solchen
fall ab und sie haben eben mit recht
nach dem strafrechtlichen
gefragt da ist ja da sind die normen ja
auch streng bei uns weil sie weil sie
natürlich eigentlich den das interesse
haben ja gerade die demokratie die auf
einer freien offenen öffentlichkeit und
der möglichkeit des offenen streits
beruht zu schützen und deswegen gibt es
ja sozusagen so gestaffelte
maßnahmen und muss man einfach
feststellen selbst die einstufung im
bewertungsbericht als verdachtsfall es
gilt dann ja auch analog etwa in der
politik bei der afg oder einigen ihrer
gruppierungen die ist eben noch kein
kein verbot noch lange kein verbot wurde
er aber noch lange kein verbot exakt und
und wer eben meint dass dieser dass
dieser verein verboten gehört der findet
ja im verfassungsschutzbericht
entsprechende informationen der kann
sich dann ja an den bundesinnenminister
wenden und kann den bundesinnenminister
auffordern diesen diesen diesen verein
zu verbieten aber solange das nicht der
fall ist wird eben wird eben hier nur
nach einem bloßen verdacht
gehandelt und da er sich zu wenig das
ist so wenig finde ich jedenfalls für
eine auf eine organisation wie die
buchmesse das muss man vielleicht noch
mal aktien haben das ganze hat ja
wirklich auch sehr spannende rechtliche
dimensionen die wir jetzt hier so
vorsichtig rein
gleiten denn es steht natürlich immer im
raum die meinungsfreiheit nach artikel 5
des grundgesetzes eine auf die wird sich
so ein verlag auch berufen können und
die frage ist sozusagen welche
möglichkeiten hat überhaupt die
buchmesse verlage einfach
rauszuschmeißen das ist ja gar nicht so
einfach ja das scheint mir auch so und
wäre ich natürlich auch auf ihre ist
nicht nur ist natürlich auch auf ihre
juristische einschätzung dann dann dann
gespannt also die buchmesse hat sich in
der tat eben auch mit sehr eindeutigen
und klaren
stellungnahmen auf die meinungsfreiheit
berufen und ich glaube wichtig ist da zu
sehen dass dass es eine doppelte
berufung ist und zwar sowohl eine
rechtliche position als auch eine über
das juristische hinausgehende position
wo die buchmesse eine
selbstverpflichtung sieht im zweifel für
die liberalität im zweifel für die
offenheit im zweifel für das hinnehmen
der bloßen präsenz auch von anstößiger
literatur
und so das so dass schon diese kampagne
einiger
leute im literaturbetrieb
aus sicht der der buchmesse und des
börsenvereins für den deutschen
buchhandel also vom juristischen
abgesehen eigentlich schon deswegen so
bedenklich und gefährlich ist weil daran
anstoß genommen wird das denn das
buchmesse und börsenverein vielleicht
sogar über ihre rechtlichen
verpflichtungen hinaus eben sagen wir
sind eine gesamtorganisation sämtlicher
verlage in deutschland in so lange mit
jung europa ist ja auch mitglieder genau
börsenverein des deutschen buchhandels
genau und und dann kommen wir eben zu
dem rechtlichen dass die buchmesse die
direktere buchmesse jürgen boos zu
verstehen gegeben hat dass die buchmesse
eben damit rechnet dass im fall eines
ausschlusses denn nur damit begründet
wurde dass würde dass eben diese diese
ideen
möglicherweise verfassungsfeindlich sind
dass das halt vor gericht angegriffen
werden könnte wäre auch übrigens ja
nicht das erste mal fand sehr spannend
sie haben ein urteil aus dem jahr 1958
ausgegraben
oberlandesgericht frankfurt wo ist
tatsächlich in parallelen pfeil gartner
also schon in den späten 50er jahren ja
das ist ja ich hab's nicht selber
ausgegraben und dann da auch profitiert
vom lebendigen
lebendige debatten medium twitter wo ja
viel auch dieses dieses streits geführt
wird wohl auch viel viel
eskalation rhetorische eskalation
betrieben wird aber ich will jetzt auch
gern mal was positives sagen dass ich
eben diesen diesen frühen fund also
jemanden verdanke der wird das eben
kannte diesen diesem fall und das ist
schon extrem interessant da ging es in
den 50er jahren um einen verlag in
göttingen der hieß plätze verlag und der
leiter war ein
ehemaliger ss-mann und in diesem verlag
ist ist echte nazi literatur erschienen
unter anderem
angebliche dann wohl auch zum teil
gefälschte letzte aufzeichnung von
alfred rosenberg also wirklich solches
wirklich giftiges giftiges zeug
und 1955 gab es dann auf der auf der
buchmesse ja im grunde etwas ähnliches
wie wir jetzt sehen sogar noch
eigentlich eine eskalationsstufe bereits
höher es gab nämlich was man selbst
justiz dann realistische nennen muss da
hatten sich andere verleger
zusammengetan die das eben störte dass
dieser nazi verlag da zehn jahre jahren
nach 144 6 jahre nach gründung der
bundesrepublik dass da also ein nazi
verlag nazi literatur ausstellt und
natürlich auch nazis an diesem an diesem
stand war und dann sind eben diese diese
verleger sind dann eben zu diesem stand
gegangen und haben dann eben mit einer
handgreiflichen demonstration dafür
gesorgt dass dieser fall dieser stand
dicht gemacht hat also die hand der
vergewaltiger gesetzen unserem archiv
habe ich jetzt nicht keine einzelheiten
darüber gefunden eben nur diese
grundsätzliche beschreibung das ist eben
eine aktion war die von anderen
ausstellern ausging dass es scheint mir
auch wichtig und das ist ja auch
durchaus eine parallele eben zu heute
und wie ging dann die geschichte weiter
dann wurde im jahr darauf 19 56 der
verlag tatsächlich von der buchmesse
ausgeschlossen und zwar mit folgendem
argument dass die bloße präsenz
prof geeignet ist eben zu zu provozieren
und das was man im vergangenen jahr
gesehen hat dass nämlich das ist nämlich
ein angriff dann durch durch diese als
provokateure erlebten nazi verleger und
autoren gab das genügt schon den verlag
auszuschließen dem hat sich dann in
einem in einem dann zwei jahre später
geführten rechtsstreit als noch mal eben
das länder ein gleichartiges verbot gab
das wurde dann letztlich vom
oberlandesgericht frankfurt auch
akzeptiert die haben gesagt es ist kein
problem die buchmesse ist eben nicht
verpflichtet hier jeden aussteller zu
zeigen und es genügt dass eben das eben
die
anwesenheit dieses einen ausstellers
geeignet ist den frieden zu stören da
scheint mir schon wichtig also da muss
man auch wirklich
sagen das ist ein gewichtiger
präzedenzfall insofern als ja die die
dinge noch etwas anders liegen als als
heute heute wird jedenfalls behauptet
von den leuten von jung europa würde
eine bedrohung ausgehen die wären
sozusagen und in celle gewalttäter ob es
dafür wirklich belege dass wieder einmal
ziehen gewalttäter an ich gehe ja sicher
an während während in den 80er jahren
sogar gesagt wurde wenn andere gewalt
üben die runde von der gegenseite gewalt
üben das ist schon genug um diesen um
diesen rechten verlag auszuschließen
dass mittel in der tat heutzutage
komisch das meldet komisch an und es
immer um kurzes das historische
sozusagen abzuschließen ist 1973 habe
gab es dann noch mal eine wiederholung
dieses dieses in großen ganzen vorgangs
der der verleger schützt der der früher
diesen plätze verlag geleitet hatte
hatte inzwischen inzwischen hat einen
neuen verlag gegründet der aber offenbar
einfach unter einem neuen namen das
gleiche gemacht hat und auch 1973 ist es
der buchmesse eben eben eben gelungen
die
den wind in den verlag auszuschließen
und so sagen heute eben auch leute
juristisch
müsste das eben doch auch möglich sein
mit denen mit denen mit denen mit den
gleichen mit den gleichen argumenten
wobei man dann ja einwenden kann dass
ich das sehr weit vor gedreht hatten
also es hat sich viel getan in den
vergangenen jahren im jahrzehnten der
auch der rechtsprechung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts wir haben das
lied urteil aus dem jahr 1958
interessanterweise auch aus der gleichen
gemengelagen umgekehrte fall da ging es
um erich lüth
einem sind senats direktor aus hamburg
der gegen faltrad land vorgegangen ist
also dem regisseur von jud süß also ein
propagandafilm aus der nazizeit und der
klar gesagt hat geht nicht in die filme
des dieses regisseurs die neuen filme
die in den 50er jahren daneben kam und
die asse hat er eben bis vor das
bundesverfassungsgericht gebracht diese
frage es war übrigens ein streit
zwischen privaten auch dass es ja
vielleicht wichtig also grundrechte
normalerweise sind ja abwehrrechte
gegenüber den start und damals also die
streitigkeiten zwischen errechnet und
auch herrn veit harlan dem regisseur
waren hier ein privatrechtlicher natur
eigentlich
und hier haben wir sehr in eine ähnliche
konstellation wir haben ein privates
unternehmen nämlich diesen jung verlag
und auch die buchmesse die er nun auch
keine staatliche institution es wird
vielleicht um das mit abzuschießen was
das bundesverfassungsgericht damals
gesagt hat klare marschrichtung also
hier
haben auch strahlen auch die grundrechte
auch also auch dass artikel 5
hat ihm jedenfalls in maßen auch im
privaten
seine berechtigung und das spielt eine
wichtige rolle ja das war sozusagen
punkt eins und was man vielleicht dann
noch später sagen muss jetzt in den
nächsten jahrzehnten die dann gekommen
ist und die uns zum beispiel zum
stadionverbots urteil für niveau- und
darf das ist schwingt er in diesem
verfahren auch immer mit drin da ging es
auch um eine auseinandersetzung zwischen
privaten also zwischen einem privaten
fußballfan und einem fußball stadion
betreiber der ein fußballfan
ausschließen wollte und auch da war die
frage geht es ja und inwieweit ist der
stadionbetreiber gebunden an
grundrechte und da muss man eben sagen
sagt das bundesverfassungsgericht
ja hier als auch eine bindung da
insbesondere wenn der zugang beschränkt
ist also wenn es quasi ein monopol gibt
von seiten des privaten stadionbetreiber
sie muss man hier in der tat bei der
buchmesse auch sagen das würde ich eben
auch so sehen das jedenfalls wie immer
das dann in erwähnten wenn es drauf
ankäme und dass die gerichte entscheiden
würden wie immer das dann dann ausgehen
mag ich finde eben auch man muss die
muss auch diese strukturellen
überlegungen da sehen man muss auch den
sehen dass gerade bei der
meinungsfreiheit des
bundesverfassungsgerichts aus sehr guten
gründen eben auch den wert und grund
entscheidungs charakter
der meinungsfreiheit im sinne es soll
wirklich auch im zweifel eben die freie
meinung geäußert und zwar scharf
deutlich sogar verletzend das steht ja
alles in den verfassungsgerichts urteil
zur meinungsfreiheit drin das davon lebt
die demokratie das dass es so wenig wie
möglich reglementiert wird der mal der
meinungsstreit und dann wird immer
gesagt ja aber die die meinungsfreiheit
wie der halle grundrechte von
ursprünglich richtet sich doch
eigentlich gegen den staat hier muss ich
offen sagen diejenigen die die da diese
kampagne gegen diesen diesen diesem
verlag den ich den ich jetzt gar nicht
mit seinen ideen verteidigen möchte ich
möchte ja eigentlich nur verteidigen
dass das eben diese ideen genauso
diskutiert werden können dass man in den
büchern eben blättern kann auf so einer
buchmesse wo einfach alle verlage sind
wie wir wie alle anderen auch und hier
geht es ihm ja wirklich um die
frankfurter buchmesse das muss man noch
mal ganz realistisch beschreiben es ist
genau wie sie sagen es ist eine quasi
monopolistischer struktur der im
börsenverein sind alle verlage mitglied
und die buchmesse ist die große
möglichkeit im jahr für die verlage dann
bei einem literatur interessierten
publikum und auch einen professionellen
publikum sich persönlich mit allem was
dazugehört von ihrem programm eben
bekannt zu machen und deswegen kann man
tatsächlich von der logik der
meinungsfreiheit her meiner meinung nach
ist es ganz schwer dazu sagen ja das ist
ja das ist eine private sache wie wenn
jemand irgendwo literatur festival
gründet mit privatem geld und daneben
die autoren sondern lieblingsautoren
oder lieblingsfahrer verlage ein einlädt
hier würde würde meiner meinung nach dem
dem dem verlag der dort ausgeschlossen
wird nur wegen der ideen
der bücher würde ein eindeutiger
wirtschaftlicher nachteil entstehen und
vor allem würde ja auch mit einem stigma
versehen weil es immer dann heißen würde
bei allen möglichen anderen allen
zusammenhängen würde man sagen ja das
ist ja der der verlag der noch nicht mal
auf der buchmesse ausstellen davor alle
anderen verlage aus stand halte ich
ihnen mal vor was ich auf twitter auch
immer wieder ventiliert wurde nun lässt
es sich ja auch leicht argumentieren als
weiser mann der solche anfeindungen
nicht zu befürchten hat von den leuten
die da womöglich an diesem jungen europa
verlag stand
ein und ausgehen was sagen sie denn
tatsächlich zu den leuten die da auch um
ihr leib und leben ich sage da das
gleiche wie wenn es hier um einen um
einen linksradikalen verlag ginge denn
das ist auch wieder so eine blindheit
und einseitigkeit und es wird so häufig
von links gesagt irgendwelche
institutionen sind auf dem rechten auge
blind und man kann aber und sollte wenn
es um fragen der toleranz geht auch mal
die die perspektive umkehren es gibt
genug extrem linke verlage die auch die
auch ausstellen auf der frankfurter
buchmesse und die ziehen auch ihr
publikum an die haben halt ihr autonomes
publikum und da wäre jetzt die analogie
wirklich die dass man dann sein dass man
dann sagen würde ja die sollen auch
nicht ausstellen denn man weiß ja leute
die in connewitz gegen die polizei
randalieren oder in kreuzberg ja das
sind die gleichen die spaß haben an
dieser lektüre denn weiter geht es ja
nicht hier bei dem jung europa verlag es
ist ja nicht so dass gesagt wird die
person
die die frau konnte oder auch nur die
eine eine andere autorin die sich
ähnlich geäussert hat die frau konnte
mit mit körperlicher gewalt bedroht hat
diese person iks arbeitet für den jung
europa verlag oder diese person hat ein
buch im jungen europa verlag oder diese
person ist eingeladen am stand von jung
europa verlag einen vortrag zu halten
alle solche konkreten anhaltspunkte gibt
es nicht und es wundert einen noch nicht
dass es die nicht gibt denn wenn es die
gäbe wäre es ja viel einfacher dann
könnte man ja sagen
jetzt soll die buchmesse erstmal ein
haus brot aus sprechen gegen diese
person die einer schriftstellerin gewalt
angedroht hat aber diese art von von
konkret belegbaren verdacht gibt es hier
nun mal nicht und deswegen hat der
buchmesse ja gesagt selbstverständlich
garantieren wir die die sicherheit für
jeden besucher jede besucherin der
buchmesse und wenn jemand wenn jemand
eine eine exponierte schriftstellerin
die das erlebt hat dass das das
rechtsradikale die ja auch gar keine
anregung durch bücher brauchen um linke
und nach ihrem heim und stand
deutschland gehörende autorinnen
anzugreifen wenn wenn wenn wenn solche
autoren meinen wenn sie sich auf so
einen großen öffentlichen raum der quasi
anonym ist wie die buch meiste begeben
da sind sie nicht sicher da hat die
buchmesse ja gesagt selbstverständlich
übernehmen wir da die
sicherheitsvorkehrungen aber dass das
wurde eben alles nicht nicht gewollt
meint man wollte eben hinaus meiner
meinung nach auf einer sozusagen
erweiterung des begriffs von
unsicherheit die vorstellung ist die
alleine in dem dieser verlag seine
bücher dorthin liegt und man in den
büchern blättern kann allein dadurch
verbreiten sich die angeblichen
rassistischen oder ja tatsächlich
mindestens nationalistischen ideen
allein dadurch wird gewalt gefördert
dass diese ideen tatsächlich solche
solche äußerst üblen konsequenzen haben
können das ist in der tat der fall aber
die antwort darauf kann doch nicht sein
dass man vorsorglich alle bücher
verbietet die jemand lesen kann der dann
auf die idee kommt sowas wie den mord an
wollte look gezwungen habe ehrlich
gesagt es geht ja gar nicht umgeht ist
verbot der bücher so das wäre noch einen
schritt weiter das ist ja aber das da
bin ich eben auch so ein bisschen ein
bisschen nicht erkenne auch das argument
aber ich würde sagen das liegt eben in
der in der in der konsequenz und wenn
man es sich auch historisch ansieht dann
dann dann hängt es eben wirklich eng
zusammen das dass das eben man wenn man
so weit geht dass man sagt hier ein ein
verlag ist als solcher schon mit den
titeln die er verlegt das waren hier in
den 50er jahren daneben titel die die
mehr oder weniger ausdrücklich zur
wiedererrichtung des dritten reiches
aufgefordert haben oder auch in der
damaligen sicht ebenfalls als genauso
gefährlich eingeschätzte literatur die
daneben sich für die dänen aus der ddr
kam oder für die ddr aus ausgesprochen
hat ist
der ich sehe keinen wirklichen
unterschied das liegt in der konsequenz
wenn man sagt wir wollen das hier nicht
tolerieren wir wollen das nicht wir
wollen das nicht dulden dass in einem
kleinen stand in einer riesigen
messehalle diese bücher aus legen dann
sagt man de facto eigentlich auch dass
die bücher nicht nicht verlegt werden
sollten und in den 50er jahren war
übrigens und dass wir wenn man dann wenn
man dann sie mit ihren juristischen
kollegen darüber diskutieren würden was
würden wir dann erwarten wenn es heute
nochmal vor gericht käme die frage wie
sie in den 50er jahren vom
oberlandesgericht frankfurt entschieden
wurde also ein punkt dem jeder ins auge
gestochen ist ist eben dass es damals
hier noch einen paragrafen im
strafgesetzbuch gab § 93 der eben die
verbreitung staatsgefährdender schriften
mit verbot belegte und dieser paragraph
ist eben 1968 bei einer der großen
strafrechtsreform
abgeschafft worden und das ist auch ein
großer liberalisierung fortschritt unser
staat schützt sich immer noch aber er
schützt sich eigentlich nicht
unmittelbar gegen indem er bücher
verbietet von denen er meint das als als
solchen von ihnen eine gefahr ausgehen
könnte und das ist muss man dann glaube
ich schon noch mal aussehen als die
faktischen unterschied zwischen 1958 und
heute damals gab es eben wirklich die
nazis es gab auch noch verschwörerische
nazi strukturen von leuten die sich
jedenfalls eingebildet haben die
bundesrepublik zu stürzen und durch
durch ein nazi regime zu ersetzen heute
hingegen ist das meiner meinung nach zum
glück natürlich vor allem rhetorik und
eben auch überschießende und grobe
rhetorik wenn man heute sagt nazis sind
doch alles nazi ehrlich und dass der
laden schreiben mit den ns
attentaten und auch mit dem was wir an
rechtsradikaler gewalt auf der straße
sehen würde ich da mal meine zweifel
anmelden wir haben aber was natürlich
die afg jetzt an geht nicht da würde ich
auch sagen ich stehe unter dem eindruck
dass der konstituierenden sitzung des
bundestages gestern wo ich da war wo
auch sehr vehement die gräben auch
aufgeworfen wurden zwischen den zwischen
der afg und allen anderen parteien muss
man ehrlicherweise sagen dafür die ich
ihnen recht geben das ist vor allen
dingen rhetorik aber auch rhetorik die
natürlich auch zu schlimmen führen kann
ja ich würde aber trotzdem war dann
trotzdem
dann noch mal versuchen zu zu
differenzieren also natürlich der nsu
und seine seine unterschätzung ist ein
ist ein schlimmes und gruseliges klaren
ja ist ein ist ein eklatantes versagen
aber was meines wissens noch nicht
aufgedeckt wurde ist sind strukturen wo
innerhalb des staatsapparates aus
ideologischer zustimmung zum zum nsu
dass das tatsächlich natürlich
staatsgefährdende handeln dieser
terroristen gedeckt worden wäre wobei
was wir jetzt gerade in der hessischen
polizei sehen ist an einen
rechtsradikalen
ja verbindung ist wirklich sehr
besorgnis und 13
trotzdem ist es was anderes als auf der
ebene zum der dessen was wir jedenfalls
wissen über die über die politischen
handlung ist es was anderes als wenn in
den 50er jahren dieser plätze verlag
eben eben persönliche
verstrickungen und direkte verbindungen
hatte mit einer gruppe von alten nazis
die damals ja richtig den diese
untergruppe naumann die damals den
fdp-landesverband richtig gekapert
hatten und da möchte ich doch noch ein
bisschen einfach mal den kontrast
betonen der damalige verlag der
ausgeschlossen wurde dieser damalige
rechtsradikale nazi verlag der presse
verlag der war grob jetzt sozusagen
zugespitzt gesagt der literarische arm
eines nazi verband innerhalb der fdp der
jetzige verlag der jung europa verlag
ist er ist dann der literarische arm
eines rechtsradikalen
vereins der im verfassungsschutzbericht
steht aber der unseres wissens eben eben
nicht von irgendwelchen
fdp oder cdu oder oder wagenknecht
flügel in der linkspartei
bedeuten irgendwie er irgendwie gedeckt
wird und eben verbindung zu achten
natürlich hat ja aber die afd es ist
eben auch nicht verboten und sollte eben
gleich gleich behandelt werden und wenn
die afg einen partei verlag gründen
möchte würde ich eben sagen ja die kann
man dann halt auch nicht von der
frankfurter und davon der von der
frankfurter buchmesse ausschließen was
nicht wundert in dieser diskussion ist
dass von den von der von der linken also
vergessen zu sein scheint wie hoch die
kosten und die kollateralschäden sind
wenn man einmal anfängt die die ganze
politische ideen welt von vornherein
unter so polizeilichen augen zu
betrachten und im zweifel lieber dinge
zu verbieten und leuten den den mund
auch zu verbieten herbern hast das war
jetzt ein sehr leidenschaftlicher appell
für die meinungsfreiheit
dafür danke ich ihnen sehr
bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
ja und dann sind wir jetzt auch schon
bei den nachträgen pia du wolltest uns
noch etwas zu dem befangenheitsantrag
gegen die bundesverfassungsgericht sagen
der hat nämlich der anwalt niko härting
noch mal nachgelegt gehören auch niko
härting gibt nicht auf wir haben darüber
in der letzten folge relativ ausführlich
gesprochen das bundesverfassungsgericht
hat nämlich einen befangenheitsantrag
eben von dem anwalt niko härting aus
berlin für die freien wähler die er
vertritt abgelehnt und zwar hatte niko
härting einen befangenheitsantrag
gestellt gegen stephan harbarth und
susanne baer wie gesagt bitte
detaillierter nachhören in der
vergangenen folge es ging aber darum
dass alle richterinnen und richter des
ersten senats sich getroffen haben zu
einem abendessen mit mitgliedern der
bundesregierung und zwar wurde bei
diesem abendessen gesprochen aufdrängen
vom vorsitzenden stephan harbarth über
das thema entscheidung unter
unsicherheiten und das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat aber gesagt
nein das hat uns alles nicht befangen
gemacht und niko härting hat jetzt noch
mal nachgelegt und zwar hat er eine
gegenvorstellung erhoben zu diesem
beschluss des bundesverfassungsgerichts
das ist ein lehrer gehen und darum los
das musste ich auch erstmal nach checken
das ist ein mehr oder weniger formloses
rechtsmittel das ist so ein bisschen wie
eine anhörungsrüge
dhs man rückt dass das rechtliche gehör
verletzt worden ist also das ist
bestürzt aber deckel 103 grundgesetz und
das gilt nur in verfahren in denen es
kein anderes rechtsmittel mehr gibt dass
man sagt liebes gericht ihr habt mir gar
nicht richtig zugehört sozusagen geht um
so eine art gehört werden als verfahrens
kann also im grunde aber ist seine
hauptargument ihr seid gar nicht auf
meine argumente eingegangen was er auch
schon ziemlich duster tobak ist genau
also er sagt irgendwie das
bundesverfassungsgericht hat sich in
dieser ablehnung des beweis des
befangenheitsantrags pardon gar nicht
damit beschäftigt was wir eigentlich
gesagt haben denn die haben nur sowas
gesagt wie na ja dieses thema
entscheidungen unter unsicherheiten das
muss ich ja gar nicht corona beziehen
und so sondern und niko härting gesagt
leute das ist doch überhaupt nicht der
punkt und das hatten wir tatsächlich
auch in der vergangenen woche schon
angesprochen sondern der punkt beim
befangenheitsantrag ist ja immer ob es
einen bösen schein gibt also ob aus
sicht des beschwerdeführenden in diesem
fall eben der freien wähler der böse
schein entstehen könnte das
möglicherweise das gericht nicht
unbefangen ist es also und das ist
tatsächlich auch so ein klassiker den
das bundesverfassungsgericht auch immer
selbst sich selbst da zitiert ob bei
vernünftiger würdigung aller umstände
anlass besteht an der
unvoreingenommenheit zweifeln und dass
es immer darum geht bereits den bösen
schein einer möglicherweise fehlenden
unvoreingenommen hat zu vermeiden so und
wie reagiert jetzt das gericht auf die
gegenvorstellung also was hat es denn
das weiß man nicht genau
also es ist wohl so dass tatsächlich das
gericht einfach nur darüber entscheiden
muss wie ist darüber entscheiden muss
dafür gibt es überhaupt keine vorgaben
weil es eben wirklich so ein formloses
rechtsmittel ist das jedenfalls fürs
bundesverfassungsgericht nirgends
geregelt ist also es gibt keinerlei
regelung dazu und niko härting
argumentiert eben im prinzip damit dass
er sagt naja kann ja nicht sein dass
wenn es bei allen anderen gerichten
existiert und darin die
verfahrensordnung aufgenommen wurde und
übrigens auch vom
bundesverfassungsgericht selbst erfunden
wurde diese anhörungsrüge dass das damit
quasi nicht auch beim
bundesverfassungsgericht selbst geht da
bin ich mal sehr gespannt was da
karlsruhe damit machen wird damit hat
jetzt aber das ist auch nicht bewenden
lassen sondern er hat auch noch neuen
befangenheitsantrag hinterher geschickt
und zwar gegen alle entscheidenden
richter also die über den
befangenheitsantrag negativ entschieden
haben im ersten senat und zwar mit
demselben argument sie hätten eben herrn
herbert und frau bär einseitig in schutz
genommen anstatt sich mit der relevanten
frage nach dem bösen schein zu
beschäftigen und überhaupt damit
sozusagen auf das argument der
beschwerde führen dann überhaupt
einzunehmen also er hat mich
weitergebildet
geraume und über den befangenheitsantrag
müssen sie jetzt auch noch mal
entscheiden berichtet sicher wie gesagt
gegen andere richter da kann man jetzt
auch nicht irgendwie sagen
rechtsmissbrauch oder so da glaube ich
nicht dass bevor vom
bundesverfassungsgericht herauskommt gut
dass also zum thema
befangenheitsantrag und der korona
rechtsprechung des
bundesverfassungsgerichtes du hast auch
noch ein nachtrag für uns wo genau zu
dem lustigen verfahren über das wir
letztes wochen letzte woche berichtet
haben ja da geht es um den drachen lord
da wurde jetzt das urteil
gesprochen es kam tatsächlich zu dem
befürchteten andrang obwohl wir euch ob
wir ihn ja gesagt haben da nicht hin zu
gehen aber es gibt wohl offensichtlich
viele leute die es wahrscheinlich nichts
unter unsere jugend sind dies dann traut
man so gar nicht aber ich das gut oder
schlecht findet dass man daher nicht zu
unseren was die da nicht zu unseren
hören und hören die leute deinen
gegangen sind um sich diesen prozess
anzuschauen waren wahrscheinlicher viele
der händler das drama
und die haben dann in der tat auch im
schauspiel
vorgefunden also der 32-jährige wurde
dann vergangene woche zu einer
zweijährigen haftstrafe immerhin
verurteilte wegen gefährlicher
körperverletzung und anderer straftaten
also da wurde dann offensichtlich ist
das gericht davon ausgegangen er hat
auch zugegeben dass er tatsächlich auf
den einen täter der
eingedroschen hat mit einer taschenlampe
und das dazu verletzung gab ja und das
ganze ist deswegen jetzt in einem in
einer haftstrafe gemündet weil er schon
auf bewährung verurteilt worden war also
es ihm das zweite verfahren bereits dem
er sich stellen muss und das war im
sommer wurde er eine entschuldigung im
september 2009 10 wurde er schon mal
verurteilt wegen gefährlicher
körperverletzung und da war es nur eine
bewährungsstrafe arbeit diesen
neuerlichen taten beging er in während
dieser
bewährungszeit und deswegen muss er
jetzt tatsächlich in haft ja genau also
von sozialstunden wie ich letzte woche
noch mutig gesagt hatte weil ich nämlich
tatsächlich nicht auf dem schirm hatte
dass er schon auf bewährung draußen war
das heißt wenn man dann zum zweiten mal
verurteilt wird noch während der
bewährungszeit dann wird das feld das
ganze natürlich härter aus so geschehen
jetzt in zwei jahre ohne bewährung
allerdings habe ich im kopf corinna
korrigiere mich dass die
staatsanwaltschaft schon
revision eine berufung eingelegt hat
oder das ist auch wahr also auch da wird
es jetzt noch zu weiteren zu einem
weiteren prozess aller voraussicht nach
kommt wir halten sie wir halten euch auf
dem laufenden
und sind dann jetzt beim gerechten unter
der woche pia da hast du uns was schönes
mitgebracht das kommt diese woche vom
landessozialgericht niedersachsen bremen
und das gericht hat entschieden dass die
gesetzliche krankenversicherung nachdem
sie eine brust-op bewilligt hat auch die
notwendige folge op tragen muss jetzt
könnte man erst mal sagen okay super
bowl ring das sollte irgendwie klar sein
wenn es um eine notwendige folge op geht
aber anderer ansicht war in diesem fall
die krankenkasse und der fall ist auch
irgendwie gar nicht so wie soll ich
sagen gala mäßig wie er klingt sondern
es ging um eine 33-jährige aus friesland
und die hatte anlage bedingt eine
einseitige fehlbildung der brust also
quasi die brust asymmetrisch
ausgestaltet das ist dann 2017
korrigiert worden durch eine operation
und die ärzte haben mir damals geraten
weil sie eben noch sehr junges mit 33
das ist dass sie da eine transplantation
machen soll von eigenfett also es ist
kein silikon implantat eingesetzt wurden
wie man das immer so kennt bei rs ich
sage mal ästhetisch bedingten brust
operationen sondern das ist mit
eigenfett gemacht wurden und das wurde
auch von der kasse bewilligt und bezahlt
damals alles kein thema halbes jahr
später stellt sich aber heraus dass der
seiten unterschied bei den beiden
brüsten noch nicht vollständig beseitigt
war und dann hat die kasse gesagt wir
zahlen jetzt aber keine folge op weil
wir haben ja eigentlich nur meiner
korrektur per implantat zugestimmt und
außerdem jetzt kommt mein lieblings
argument die verbleibende asymmetrie sei
ja auch nur relativ geringfügig und
stelle keine anstellung mehr da deswegen
sei eine weitere operation auch
medizinisch nicht notwendig achtung sie
können ja auch einen push up bh tragen
das sei zumutbar und ausreichend da muss
man doch wirklich mal sagen skandal und
dann hat die frau gesagt das lasse ich
nicht auf mir sitzen sondern das gehe
ich ein klagen und hat jetzt auch recht
bekommen die frau hat das damit
begründet dass sie sagte na ja es ist
ganz normal dass bei dieser op mit wurde
weiteres eigenfett transplantiert werden
muss im rahmen einer zweiten op denn ein
teil des eigens wird vom körper
resorbiert und die ärzte hätten eben
auch gesagt dass eine folge op kein
problem ist wenn die kasse einmal gesagt
hat wir übernehmen das und damit hat sie
jetzt wie gesagt auch gewonnen vor dem
lsg und die sozialrichter haben gesagt
das ist eine behandlungsbedürftige
krankheit eben eine fehlbildung der
brust dafür muss die gesetzliche
krankenversicherung bezahlen und zwar
auch für die notwendige folge op denn
diese brustrekonstruktion sei mit der
ersten operation eben noch nicht
vollständig abgeschlossen gewesen
sondern bei diesem lipo filling also
diesem einsatz nicht von implantaten
sondern von körpereigenem fett seien die
volumen unterschiede methoden bedingt
und ob da eine nach korrektur
erforderlich sei das entschieden nun
nicht die krankenkasse sondern das
entschieden die behandelten ärzte und es
sei nicht der job der krankenkasse über
die konkretisierung ihres anspruchs
gegen die kasse auf übernahme dieser op
kosten zu entscheidend sondern der job
der ärzte wer da kann ich sehr recht an
was für ein gerechtes urteil da würde
ich mich voll anschließen ist
wahrscheinlich auch ein urteil mit dem
sich viele
hören auch anschließen können wenn man
weiß es nicht so genau also nach 33
jährigen zu sagen tragen sie doch mal
ein push up bh sich doch nicht mehr so
schlimm aus finde ich jetzt schon
irgendwie ein krasses argumente absolut
das sehe ich genauso so dann hätten wir
jetzt die woche ausreichend verhandeln
wie es früher in unserem claim immer so
schön hieß was bleibt jetzt noch zu
sagen ja wir danken einfach für die
aufmerksamkeit wünschen uns
unterstützung in form von abos zb
entweder für den fcz ein spruch das
magazin oder auch für faz oder sonstige
produkte aus unserem haus alles zahlt
auch auf unser podcast 1
wir wünschen uns auch feedback und da
einspruch podcast faz.de oder auf
unseren webseiten ja das war's an
hinweisen herzlichen dank für alles fürs
zuhören und eine gute woche euch da
draußen schaut der netzwoche teams
[Musik]